for my mma career
i never planned it to go that way but
yeah i didn't lose for nine years and
like that's that's pretty rare i didn't
plan for that to happen that was just
what happened okay but you also
didn't lose like the second part of your
college career my 87 i lost i won my
last 87 matches yeah
so that
didn't come along with the hatred of
losing you just i don't like losing i
still don't like it
yeah yeah
okay but you're you don't
uh you don't seem to you you seem to
kind of shrug it off a little bit okay
so like but specifically with these two
instances that you bring up with the
mosfet all
right it feels definitely so okay
all right let's let's go let's go deep
what's good so the miles without one it
feels different because um
let's for people don't know okay uh moz
videl loss was your first loss first
lawsuit in mma yes yeah yeah i think
yeah and i mean it was a dramatic loss
very dramatic and
there was this kind of build up as you
are potentially one of the greats of all
time coming into this fight
and so
there's pressure all of that so the no i
mean i i was thoroughly enjoying it i
don't know i didn't feel the pressure so
the mozzarella fight is
he got one [ __ ] move on me it's not
he beat me and if we do that again i
think i win at that point in my life for
sure i think i win
way way way more times than i lose he he
knew that too that's why he didn't he
didn't want something sounded about
agreeing and that's why i had to taunt
him and why he got so mad because i had
to continue to taunt him in order to get
him to sign right
so that one hurt because
uh and some people don't know my
memphials go through it fast i did three
fights in like uh smaller leagues i got
signed by bellator i was undefeated for
three and a half years i was 9-0
um when i got done with that in 2012 or
2013
um
i at that point in my head i was just
gonna transition to the ufc because
that's where you go i was ranked like
sixth in the world i
hadn't really had a competitive match at
the end of the bellator thing and dana
white for a reason still unknown to me
we still have this conversation i wish i
could ask i should ask him sometime um
chose to refuse me any entry into ufc he
just said i went to his office
and he literally said we're not
interested we're not going to make you
an offer did you did you mention
something too about him about the ufc
that was a year before that that was the
year before that
that might play a role in it i think so
uh yes what happened the year before
that was
uh i called him a liar which but listen
i'm right on this one because he said
you can't test for drugs because i'm all
natural which you can tell by my
physique um and i was always put off by
the fact that so many people cheated
and i i was very vocal about that and so
he had made some statement like oh
there's no way you could test i said
[ __ ] you you very specifically i
said usada does it for all other sports
worldwide
you can do it and then it's funny
because i hired you south a couple years
later yeah so i think he took some
offense to that but that was like a year
and
almost a year and a half i think
somewhere later
um it's not like he holds a grudge or
anything
yeah so i so i literally go to vegas
um it's a long story you can read about
it other places i i so i got released
from about it's not like this is
negotiation i got released from my
bellator contract i said i'm out of here
i'm going i'm going to go to ufc i go to
vegas and then i was told hey there's no
offer for you tough [ __ ] you know so
then
i ended up signing with one championship
i spent what three and a half years
there i won the belt in my second fight
and retained the title the entire time
and then i just again dominating people
yeah i didn't have a competitive fight
and so um i retired 18-0 never never get
and for someone who loves a challenge
never getting to really challenge myself
was incredibly frustrating and i left
the door open but i said if i ever get
the chance to prove them this world i'd
love to come back so
somehow a year later i get traded trades
that never happened and this is the one
and only trade ever
i got i've been retired for a year i got
traded i get to come back i fight robbie
lawler the first fight i win and then
essentially they're saying okay if you
fight uh you know if you beat george
you're gonna get the title [ __ ] against
marty and
um
it's like this is this is what i've been
working for the entire i've been trying
to prove the best part of the world for
the last 10 years and i've not been
afforded this opportunity
um
so when i lost to george that was hard
because i it was is something that
i had waited for for a really really
long time it was something that i you
know i thought i could compete for and i
never got the opportunity to do so that
one was hard um at the same time from
like just the competitive logistics like
he got me with one move it wasn't like
he beat my ass for 15 minutes and i got
beat a bunch of different ways
so that was like
[ __ ] like if i get it again i could have
done it but i'm not i'm not they're not
gonna let me have it again it's not like
wrestling where you could go the next
year or the next week or whatever you
know you lose a big tens you go to
nationals two weeks later
does that loss change you
in any way your psychology i don't i
don't think so it's the first loss
i mean had i had i
had a longer mma career post that yeah
there definitely would have been a lot
of time spent
getting better at the end the entry
point to the takedown right which i
already spent time there um i don't i
and i hate making excuses but yeah the
hip the hinging of my hip what i
couldn't do was preventing me from doing
some things and it's why if you look at
the fight i'm like bent over as they go
for the double leg
yeah so what happened for people who
don't know you want in for a double leg
and he
specifically the way he did that knee
was kind of different than the way
anyone had thrown flying knees before
most people go more just from a stand
straight vertical whereas he took a few
like running steps and went more you
know the trajectory of the angle was
different um so i think that's kind of
probably why it caught
you know
i think a lot of things in combat well
probably everything but i focus
specifically on happen subconsciously
like our brain is reading what's coming
at us
and and a lot of times it's stuff we've
seen before so we can judge how to move
correctly yeah you miss red because it's
something you haven't seen head for had
not seen him come at that specific angle
yeah so that loss was really hard with
the burrows one
i told you i knew i was going to lose so
it was like yeah whatever you know i'm
taking this because i want to put the
sport of wrestling out there in a big
way i want to help them raise a lot of
money we sold at madison square garden
hulu theater and we raised a whole bunch
of money so my goals were accomplished
jake paul fight i took it because they
paid me a bunch of money and i thought
it was gonna be fun did i have any
illusion i was a great boxer no
illusions whatsoever would i have
preferred to win absolutely but you know
like i told everyone whether i win or
lose on saturday night i'm going to be
back coaching wrestling on monday
because that's what i enjoy doing and i
was back coaching wrestling on monday
and once a month these middle school
kids give me a little bit [ __ ] about it
and
that's it but
where were you
in terms of your shape and how you felt
in the mazadal fight
would you say you're on the i mean it's
a difficult question to ask of
of a world-class athlete but like were
you
past peak
oh yeah yeah
and that's what i don't know i don't
know why guys like to lie about that i
mean the peak for me was really
evidently in my late 20s um
and maybe they are all fueled by
extra supplements i don't know but for
me that that was evident but you get
this so you get this crosshair where
um you're if you're smart like you know
like i mentioned john bros was you're
still gaining wisdom you're gaining
strategy you're gaining a lot of things
right and so while your physicality may
go down your overall skill level still
may be rising especially in mma because
people usually start later
because they're gaining wisdom strategy
all the maybe more tools in their
toolbox right they're getting all these
things so their actual competitive peak
despite their athletic peak going down
might still be
a few years past that right because
these things are crossing um no so i
thought i was great obviously the hip
was an issue
um
it's funny because so the
i knew i had a lot of pain here and i
knew it was because of this it was like
okay whenever i'm done i'll just get it
taken care of whatever
uh but i every time i train i have pain
kind of like all up my back
and the day after the surgery
i woke up and there was no pain on the
right side of my surgery on the left
side there's no pain in the right side
of my back that's [ __ ] weird like
every every morning i wake up there's a
lot of pain there you know
um i'm like okay i want my pain pills
maybe it'll maybe it'll come back
tomorrow and this that's really never
never been back since
so it's weird because it was like this i
thought this was affecting this but it
was affecting
all the way across my whole back so you
know if i get to get a new hip honestly
if i if i
i don't know it's going to change the
competitive outcome whatsoever
if i had known how good the hip
replacement was going to be
i would have done it the second i
retired from one championship in
november of 2017 i would have my hip
surgery scheduled for december 1. just
from a lifestyle standpoint i could only
sleep in one position
there's a lot of things i couldn't do i
was in a lot of pain um so i would have
done that a lot earlier but no from my
athletic point i was ready just [ __ ]
goes wrong sometimes
you